let's talk about the nuke event in call
of duty i'm joined here by richie
bracamonte and we're gonna go over
how odd the rollout's been so far what
some of the leaks and rumors are
pointing to
in the future and i don't know if we
think it's even gonna happen at this
point
this episode is brought to you by
daylight savings daylight savings
screw your sleep schedule
all right richie let's talk about what's
been happening so far
because it's kind of odd it is odd we're
getting a lot of mixed messages from
call of duty over on twitter about this
whole zombie outbreak
and possibly leading to some sort of
bigger event like the nuke
the the next season will end april 20th
and that's our that's our latest date
like our big anchor date to see if
something happens but at this point it's
sort of
mixed messages between ending the
zombies outbreak event
and the future of war zone yeah how
freaking weird is that that the
zombie event ended before the zombies
spread on the warzone map i'm
trying to figure out what they were
attempting to accomplish with that other
than
maybe push people to to buy cold war and
play the outbreak mode in cold war
but you would think that their main mode
involving zombies
would tie into warzone where the zombies
are spreading they've also just done a
lot
of really weird stuff like one week they
tweeted that zombies were leaving the
ship but the zombies didn't leave the
ship for an entire week
and then just this week they tweeted
enemies both living and undead are all
around the shipwreck
how many can you find um no they aren't
so like that was tweeted out this week
the zombies already moved to the prison
and then they're going to the hospital
and they keep removing the challenge
machines from places they've already
been
and by the way like so far the zombie
event has pretty much come down to a
zombie challenge machine moving a couple
hundred yards in
any given direction like every two weeks
or something like that
so the rollout of this season and
supposedly what's leading up to a nuke
event
has been slow and bizarre and starting
to actually wonder if they're going to
do
much this season other than just roll
out like
an ltm at the very end between season
two and season three which
as you mentioned you know given a
10-week run of seasons should happen
sometime mid april this whole nuke
event's been rumored for
almost a year now erin i found a video
file of
me capturing footage of the damn before
you know before the noog happened and
that was dated last june this whole
nuke event has been teased forever so
about that
activision blizzard's chief revenue
officer brandon snow just did a really
interesting interview with inverse
there's some things that he was saying
that made me think that either the nuke
event
is gonna happen like in season three
or maybe some of these events are a
little bit further out than we think
one thing he said was in the upcoming
seasons you're gonna see some really
cool new stuff that warzone has never
done before
he said seasons not season so
i don't know maybe he's just really well
media trained and he's hiding you know
what he means here but he didn't say
this season you're gonna see this stuff
he said seasons which makes me think
they have stuff planned out for the next
couple of seasons that they're not ready
for just yet
he then followed that up by saying
something along the lines of if we were
to check back with each other in about
four to five weeks we might be able to
speak a little bit more specifically
four to five weeks is again you know
mid-april
when we're expecting the season two
season three changeover
so what this is saying to me is that
this is gonna be a really slow roll
season
i i don't know if a lot's gonna happen
in season two it looks like they're not
even ready to talk about
a lot of these events until the
beginning of season three so i'm now
starting to wonder if
more is gonna happen in season three and
season four okay so there's a whole
other thing that we should talk about
here
which is the way that this is being
marketed this nuke event is being
marketed in typical treyarch fashion and
what they like to do is they like to
tease things with alternate reality
games they sent
this like giant projector oh i'm gonna
hold it up here
you took to the trail quickly firing up
old projectors and shining a light on
classified intelligence
they sent that giant projector to us
before they rolled out cold war
and like we didn't really know what to
do with it and it was like an
announcement that was gonna happen
anyway
so that's a very classic treyarch
they've been sending these like teases
about the ghoul ag
to different youtubers right now
indicating like maybe that the zombies
are evolving
so here's the problem with that the
modern warfare crowd doesn't really
care about alternate reality games like
there's a very hardcore
zombies fan base that you know treyarch
has
that love this stuff and they love all
these little teases but they seldom lead
up to anything more than just like an
official announcement
which is what the vast majority of
modern warfare players care about also
warzone is free to play so the people
who are playing warzone
aren't really dialed in on these little
args so example another example of what
they did
when they sent me that projector was
pawn takes pawn which was this like
giant sprawling like mystery that
happened across the internet
that wound up showing that like bowman's
kid was still alive which was
an ice cube's child in the game and then
they did nothing with it
i forgot about that aaron like that was
such a big
like they fluffed up all of that stuff
for nothing really like i was like
what's the bottom line here with
pawn takes pawn and it's like oh yeah
the bottom line is
cold war is coming out like what are
they doing with i don't know i totally
forgot about the whole bowman thing
and because it led to nowhere like i
thought he might be
in the campaign somehow i mean it takes
place uh in the 80s well after the first
bowman you know played by ice cube but
they didn't run with that at least as
far as i know nothing in any big
capacity but
they they really do like to try our
gloves to play these like mind games it
kind of spawns from like
people who love to dig around for easter
eggs and zombies but that bled into like
the whole cold war thing and i don't
know if everyone's buying it to me it
was just kind of like
i'm behind again i gotta go i gotta
catch up and try to put this together
through every youtuber who got this care
package like and it's just
kind of another example of why the
modern warfare audience
and the cold war audience don't really
belong together this is not something
that the modern warfare audience is
really going to gravitate towards
so again like you know we get a lot of
user comments about how they're throwing
modern warfare audience under the bus
for the cold war audience
it's just another example like the
modern warfare audience they just want
to have fun
they just want to enjoy the modern
warfare aspects of warzone
and they just you know they just want
this zombie event to be better than it
already is more
more along the lines of haunting of
verdance they really need to pick up the
pace on the zombie event in the warzone
map
nobody really wants this like giant slow
roll out with
nothing much happening until the end of
the season except for maybe some
very very hardcore like zombies fans who
who like
following these args but that's that's
not the mass audience
okay so that's what's going on so far in
summary we know that the next time that
a
an event could happen such as the nuke
event will be mid-april
we know we've talked a little bit about
the weird slow rollout of zombies and
the mismatch of audience
now it's time to talk about what we
actually do know about the nuke event
and all the leaks that have been coming
out lately
so for weeks now we've heard a lot of
data mined audio samples from
other game modes some include the exfol
mode that already happened
but others are kind of mysterious and
they come from people like
captain price and all these new game
modes that sound like
they take place in a zombie-infested
post-nuclear aftermath of verdansk
so it's all a matter of when but these
callouts are pretty specific about
plague zones you hear captain price in
the voice over saying
things like you know it's your last
chance to savor dance
and uh you know verdask is lost like you
can either win or lose and it's all via
a big nuclear blast you know it sounds
like this mode
you can save or dance by you know
stopping the nukes and
i don't know it it sounds like a a big a
big mix of like
uh verdansk ending game mode also with
these audio leaks we're seeing some
other game modes that might be
kind of fun and more of a distraction
but like we're talking like
car races or uh other sort of obstacle
modes that require a helicopter or
some sort of vehicle they sound fun but
that's probably all going to come
also later towards the end of the season
or at least the second half
so up next we have some comments from
you guys with some constructive feedback
for
all things call of duty our first
comment here from dylan c on youtube who
says
warzone needs more events like the
halloween or rebirth ones where there's
either new weather time of day a new map
in general on top of the event where you
can earn rewards
this zombies event feels lazy compared
to those events
i'm inclined to agree here because uh
something something like
time of day it's sort of a change that
sounds subtle but it's so cool i love
like nighttime or snow-covered maps
something to change the environment
what's more zombie than
night time right you see their glowing
eyes better it really like
enhances the event it's what the
haunting of her dance did
definitely a missed opportunity and
again the only thing going on right now
is a zombie challenge machine
is moving a couple hundred yards every
two weeks it's like
come on that's not enough yeah it's
it's a little lacking hopefully it's
just cooking to something bigger and
better but
kind of a slow roll to start with we're
at low
simmer right now there's not enough
happening right we need a hard boil
right now let's go our next comment over
on youtube is from player1 who says not
everyone likes battle royale what the
cod developers need to do
is allow a large scale tdm domination
hardpoint
and other respawn style games into
verdansk how about official death races
where the squads battled it out in
vehicles trying to make
one lap around the entire map
aaron i love this idea people already do
this
with or without being told to and it's
not it's not a mode yet but that'd be so
fun
the vehicle racing is always fun in
warzone
they kind of tweak the cars a little bit
with their turning radius but
even then it's still fun to just cruise
around in a car it's always been fun to
run over people anything with cars
in warzone is always okay by me
and if those audio leaks are true the
first set of audio leaks that richie
talked about
it basically indicated we are going to
get races so
i think we're going to get the fun side
of things the side where they may have
dropped the ball is when modern warfare
launched
and they had modes like ground war and
and they had the
ground war maps set on the same map as
warzone
i kind of thought they had a chance to
knock out battlefield for the first time
in a long time like they could have kept
expanding to larger big team battles
and they have created some new areas
like my least favorite map promenade in
ground war
but they really really could take that
further if they wanted to keep
developing in modern warfare
this is another way that they could keep
the modern warfare audience engaged is
just a ground war and just
rotate it around the verdance map
randomly something like that would be so
much fun and like who cares if it's
balanced it's just fun to
the battle on that map in game the the
map can just keep pushing from one
location to an
to another like during one match yeah
and they they're already doing this
with kingslayer trios and a couple of
other ones so they are doing
some of these modes but they really need
to do them for the modern warfare crowd
and focus back on the modern warfare
crowd and
to me that says do ground war in more
places that's how you
compete against battlefield this year
our next comment here comes from
super cooper they could have done much
more with spec ops i would have liked
more missions to play
though it felt half-assed the old modern
warfare 2 and 3 had lots of missions
compared to the new modern warfare this
ties into another comment by phelium
good hopefully the community is a step
closer to realizing the obvious
activision doesn't give an
f about their consumers other than their
yearly money injection for a half-assed
call of duty
both of these comments touched on
half-assed modes which does make me
wonder what a full-assed mode looks like
in call of duty
i i feel like modern warfare was
probably a full ass game
i mean it was like well planned out for
an entire year if that's what
everybody's getting at
yeah i would say it's a full last game
you're right spec ops was
a side mode that wasn't as good another
way
that they could keep developing the
model warfare community is take things
like
outbreak which they just did in cold war
outbreak is such a spec ops kind of mode
they could have just put that into
modern warfare also like
make a zombie infested spec ops mode or
just do that on the war zone map the way
that they probably should have you know
these are ways that that if they wanted
to keep the modern warfare audience
engaged and not feeling like they got
cast aside for the cold war audience
there are areas where they could keep
improving and hold on to their modern
warfare audience
i will die on the hill for supporting
modern warfare 2019
there's so many ways they could do it i
don't know if they will but this is just
another one
i feel like spec ops could have used
some work i mean half ass
is a pretty common comment like it was
half baked at first it wasn't even ready
i feel and it was
over it was crammed with overpowered
enemies and like
impossible objectives unless he knew
exactly we were doing
and there was fun to be had once it got
fixed
and i ended up doing every challenge
anyway but yeah compared to like modern
warfare
two or three spec ops um
it was pretty half-assed a really cool
part was how it introduced the whole
verdance map that was something that
we spec op players had an edge on it's
like oh when
when war zone and verdance goes launch
it's like i know my way around this you
know for a few weeks i had
i had to jump on people but i
overall i would say yeah in the whole in
the full ass game that is modern warfare
spec ops was a little blemish on the
butt cheek there
it wasn't perfect this is a great
analogy we're definitely running with
this in future episodes
i'm with it our next comment comes from
alejandro who says hi
my name is alejandro and i've been cod
free for three months now
i feel great uh this one hurts aaron but
you know it's it's a way for people to
it's how people play the game this
person could either just walk away from
call of duty
wait for battlefield wait for the next
call of duty or
do what we do sometimes just just take a
break you know walk away for a few
months
so alejandro enjoy your time off come
back if you want
and see what happens with this whole
nuke thing because that's we're all
waiting for
and i know you clicked on that video to
check it out too so i know you're
interested
so speaking of the next battlefield or
the next call of duty the question that
we would like to throw to you out there
is if the next battlefield or the next
call of duty is
world war ii themed or retro themed is
that enough for you
we were recently watching a video by
drifter who by the way is having some
health concerns so please go over to his
channel and wish him the best
who was talking about all the evidence
that uh sledgehammer might be delivering
another retro game so in that case let
us know if that changes what you're
going to do next
make sure to head on over to
gamespot.com and gamespot's youtube page
that's where we'll be posting these
videos and
covering the rollout of this nuke event
which will hopefully happen mid next
month
alright thanks for watching everyone
one